pour une vingtaine d'enfants du numéro 7
de la rue du dragon la rentrée scolaire
n'aura pas lieu demain
il manque des places dans les écoles du
quartier cet après midi madame ça via et
ses quatre filles sont allées à la
maternelle de la rue saint benoît pour
inscrire sabrina face aux angels mais
elles ont appris que leur dossier à me
rejoindre les autres en attendant la
mairie du xvième arrondissement je vais
surtout qu'à scolarité et je vais sans
parler parce que j'ai aucun papier avec
moi j'ai veillé à maintenir et je vais
voir une place mais je trouve une place
pourrait si madame ça via est inquiète
en revanche d'autres familles sont plus
optimistes la famille constant par
exemple espère une place pour yves qui a
10 ans et qui ne pourraient pas se
rendre chaque jour à son école d'origine
dans le 19e arrondissement
même s'ils ont peiné pis aller tout seul
mais la laisse palin gueddana des fois
humains des matrones bourgade aux
dragons choqué par l'ags est plus que
jamais des 10 euros de plus pour aller à
l'école tout celle là bas dans ce
quartier qui oibda com est là bas c'est
un type est dégueulasse et parle à peine
voilée noble autre son de cloche du côté
de la mairie du 6e arrondissement le
maire préférerait que les enfants restés
dans leur école le racing
il pourrait être préférable pour les
plus grands et à partir du moment où ils
sont déjà scolarisés dans des écoles
dans l'école de leur quartier d'origine
qu'ils puissent acheter lorsque l'arrêté
dans ces mêmes quartiers si bien
évidemment c'est c'est compatible avec
une vie normale et avec les transports
même la mairie du vième assuré ce soir
quelle serait pour le mieux
quitte à demander de l'aide à son voisin
du 7e arrondissement et dans la mesure
où l'éducation nationale fera elle aussi
des efforts